The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So I apologize.
My voice is not 100%.
So if you don't understand
what I'm saying, please ask me.
So we're going to be analyzing--
actually, not really analyzing.
We described a
second-order method
to optimize the log likelihood
in a generalized linear model,
when the parameter
of interest was beta.
So here, I'm going to rewrite
the whole thing as a beta.
So that's the equation you see.
But we really have this beta.
And at iteration k plus 1,
beta is given by beta k.
And then I have a plus sign.
And the plus, if you think of
the Fisher information at beta
k as being some number--
if you were to say
whether it's a positive
or a negative
number, it's actually
going to be a positive
number, because it's
a positive semi-definite matrix.
So since we're doing
gradient ascent,
we have a plus sign here.
And then the
direction is basically
gradient ln at beta k.
OK?
So this is the iterations that
we're trying to implement.
And we could just do this.
At each iteration, we compute
the Fisher information,
and then we do it
again and again.
All right.
That's called the
Fisher-scoring algorithm.
And I told you that this
was going to converge.
And what we're going to
try to do in this lecture
is to show how we can
re-implement this,
using iteratively
re-weighted least squares,
so that each step
of this algorithm
consists simply of solving a
weighted least square problem.
All right.
So let's go back quickly
and remind ourselves
that we are in the Gaussian--
sorry, we're in the
exponential family.
So if I look at the log
likelihood for one observation,
so here it's ln--
sorry.
This is the sum from i
equal 1 to n of yi minus--
OK, so it's yi times theta
i, sorry, minus b of theta i.
Then there's going
to be some parameter.
And then I have
plus c of yi phi.
OK.
So just the
exponential went away
when I took the log
of the likelihood.
And I have n observations,
so I'm summing
over all n observations.
All right.
Then we had a bunch of
formulas that we came up to be.
So if I look at the
expectation of yi--
so that's really the
conditional of yi, given xi.
But like here, it
really doesn't matter.
It's just going to be
different for each i.
This is denoted by mu i.
And we showed that this
was beta prime of theta i.
Then the other equation
that we found was that.
And so what we want to
model is this thing.
We want it to be equal to
xi transpose beta- sorry
g of this thing.
All right.
So that's our model.
And then we had that
the variance was also
given by the second derivative.
I'm not going to go into it.
What's actually
interesting is to see,
if we want to express theta i as
a function of xi, what we get,
going from xi to mu i by g
inverse, and then to theta i
by b inverse, we
get that theta i
is equal to h of xi transpose
beta, h of xi transpose beta,
where h is the inverse--
so which order is --this?
Is the inverse of g, and then
the compose would be prime.
OK?
So we remember that last time,
those are all computations
that we've made,
but they're going
to be useful in our derivation.
And the first thing
we did last time is
to show that, if I look now
at the derivative of the log
likelihood with respect to
one coordinate of beta, which
is going to give me the
gradient if I do that for all
the coordinates, what
we ended up finding
is that we can rewrite
it in this form, some
of yi tilde minus mu tilde.
So let's remind ourselves that--
so y tilde is just y divided--
well, OK y tilde i is yi--
is it times or divided--
times g prime of mu i.
Mu tilde i is mu i
And then that was just
an artificial thing,
so that we could actually
divide the weights by g prime.
But the real thing that built
the weights are this h prime.
And there's this
normalization factor.
And so if we read it
like that-- so if I also
write that wi is h prime of
xi transpose beta divided
by g prime of mu
i times phi, then
I could actually rewrite
my gradient, which
is a vector, in the
following matrix form,
the gradient ln at beta.
So the gradient of my
log likelihood of beta
took the following form.
It was x transpose w, and
then y tilde minus mu tilde.
And here, w was just
the matrix with w1,
w2, all the way to wn
on the diagonal and 0
on of the up diagonals.
OK?
So that was just
taking the derivative
and doing a slight
manipulations that said,
well, let's just divide
whatever is here by g
prime and multiply whatever
is here by g prime.
So today, we'll see why
we make this division
and multiplication by g prime,
which seems to make no sense,
but it actually comes from
the Hessian computations.
So the Hessian
computations are going
to be a little more annoying.
Actually, let me start directly
with the coordinate y's
derivative, right?
So to build this gradient,
what we used, in the end,
was that the partial derivative
of ln with respect to the gth
coordinate of beta was
equal to the sum over i
of yi tilde minus mu
i tilde times wi times
the gth coordinate of xi.
OK?
So now, let's just take
another derivative,
and that's going to give us
the entries of the Hessian.
OK, so we're going to
the second derivative.
So what I want to compute is
the derivative with respect
to beta j and beta k.
OK.
So where does beta j--
so here, I already took
the derivative with respect
to beta j.
So this is just the
derivative with respect
to beta k of the derivative
with respect to beta j.
So what I need to do is to
take the derivative of this guy
with respect to beta k.
Where does beta k show up here?
It's set in, in two places.
AUDIENCE: In the y's?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: No,
it's not in the y's.
The y's are my data, right?
But I mean, it's
in the y tildes.
Yeah, because it's in mu, right?
Mu depends on beta.
Mu is g inverse of
xi transpose beta.
And it's also in the wi's.
Actually, everything that you
see is directly-- well, OK, w
depends on mu n on
beta explicitly.
But the rest depends only on mu.
And so we might want
to be a little--
well, we can actually use the--
did I use the
chain rule already?
Yeah, it's here.
But OK, well, let's go for it.
Oh yeah, OK.
Sorry, I should not
write it like that,
because that was actually--
right, so I make my life
miserable by just multiplying
and dividing by
this g prime of mu.
I should not do this, right?
So what I should just write
is say that this guy here--
I'm actually going to
remove the g prime of mu,
because I just make something
that depends on theta
appear when it
really should not.
So let's just look at the
last but one equality.
OK.
So that's the one over
there, and then I have xi j.
OK, so here, it make my
life much more simple,
because yi does
not depend on beta,
but this guy depends on beta,
and this guy depends on beta.
All right.
So when I take the
derivative, I'm
going to have to be a
little more careful now.
But I just have a
derivative of a product,
nothing more complicated.
So this is what?
Well, the sum is
going to be linear,
so it's going to come out.
Then I'm going to have to take
the derivative of this term.
So it's just going
to be 1 over psi.
Then the derivative
of mu i with respect
to beta k, which I will
just write like this,
times h prime of xi
transpose beta xi j.
And then I'm going to have the
other one, which is yi minus mu
i over 5 times the second
derivative of h of xi transpose
beta.
And then I'm going to
take the derivative
of this guy with respect to beta
j with beta k, which is just
xi k.
So I have xi j times xi k.
OK.
So I still need to
compute this guy.
So what is the
partial derivative
with respect to beta k of g?
So mu is g of--
worry, it's g inverse
of xi transpose beta.
OK?
So what do I get?
Well, I'm going
to get definitely
the second derivative of g.
Well, OK, that's
actually not a bad idea.
Well, no, that's OK.
I can make the second--
what makes my life
easier, actually?
Give me one second.
Well, there's no
one that actually
makes my life so much easier.
Let's just write it.
Let's go with this guy.
So it's going to be g prime
prime of xi transpose beta
times xi k.
OK?
So now, what do I have
if I collect my terms?
I have that this whole thing
here, the second derivative is,
well, I have the sum
from 1 equal 1 to n.
Then I have terms that
I can factor out, right?
Both of these guys have xi j,
and this guy pulls out an xi k.
And it's also here, xi
j times xi k, right?
So everybody here is xi j xi k.
And now, I just have to take
the terms that I have here.
The 1 over phi, I can
actually pull out in front.
And I'm left with the
second derivative of g times
the first derivative of h, both
taken at xi transpose beta.
And then, I have
this yi minus mu i
times the second derivative of
h, taken at xi transpose beta.
OK.
But here, I'm looking
at Fisher scoring.
I'm not looking at
Newton's method, which
means that I can actually
take the expectation
of the second derivative.
So when I start taking
the expectation,
what's going to happen--
so if I take the expectation
of this whole thing
here, well, this guy, it's not--
and when I say expectation,
it's always conditionally on xi.
So let's write it--
x1 xn.
So I take conditional.
This is just deterministic.
But what is the
conditional expectation
of yi minus mu i times this
guy, conditionally on xi?
0, right?
Because this is just the
conditional expectation of yi,
and everything else
depends on xi only,
so I can push it out of the
conditional expectation.
So I'm left only with this term.
OK.
So now I need to--
sorry, and I have
xi xj, xi j xi j.
OK
So now, I want to go to
something that's slightly more
convenient for me.
So maybe we can
skip that part here,
because this is not going to
be convenient for me anyway.
So I just want to go back to
something that looks eventually
like this.
OK, that's what
I'm going to want.
So I need to have my xi show
up with some weight somehow.
And the weight should involve
h prime divided by g prime.
Again, the reason why I want
to see g prime coming back
is because I had g prime
coming in the original w.
This is actually the
same definition as the w
that I used when I was
computing the gradient.
Those are exactly
these w's, those guys.
So I need to have g
prime that shows up.
And that's where
I'm going to have
to make a little bit
of computation here.
And it's coming from this
kind of consideration.
OK?
So this thing here--
well, actually, I'm missing
the phi over there, right?
There should be a phi here.
OK.
So we have exactly this thing,
because this tells me that,
if I look at the Hessian--
so this was entry-wise,
and this is exactly
the form of something
of the form of the k.
This is exactly the jth kth
entry of xi xi transpose.
Right?
We've used that before.
So if I want to write
this in a vector form,
this is just going to be the
sum of something that depends
on i times xi xi transpose.
So this is 1 over phi sum
from i equal 1 to n of g
prime prime xi transpose beta
h prime xi transpose beta xi xi
transpose.
OK?
And that's for
the entire matrix.
Here, that was just the j
kth entries of this matrix.
And you can just check
that, if I take this matrix,
the j kth entry is just the
product of the jth coordinate
and the kth coordinate of xi.
All right.
So now I need to
do my rewriting.
Can I write this?
So I'm missing
something here, right?
Oh, I know where
it's coming from.
Mu is not g prime of x beta.
Mu is g inverse
of x beta, right?
So the derivative of x
prime is not g prime prime.
It's like this guy--
no, 1 over this, right?
Yeah.
OK?
The derivative of g inverse is
1 over g prime of gene inverse.
I need you guys, OK?
All right.
So now, I'm going to
have to rewrite this.
This guy is still
going to go away.
It doesn't matter,
but now this thing
is becoming h prime over g prime
of g inverse of xi transpose
beta, which is the same
here, which is the same here.
OK?
Everybody approves?
All right.
Well, now, it's
actually much nicer.
What is g inverse of
xi transpose beta?
Well, that was exactly the
mistake that I just made,
right?
It's mu i itself.
So this guy is really
g prime of mu i.
Sorry, just the bottom, right?
So now, I have something
which looks like a sum from i
equal 1 to n of h prime
of xi transpose beta,
divided by g prime of mu i phi
times xi xi transpose, which
I can certainly write in
matrix form as x transpose wx,
where w is exactly
the same as before.
So it's w1 wn.
And wi is h prime
of xi transpose beta
divided by g prime of mu i.
There's a prime here
times phi, which
is the same that we had here.
And it's supposed to be
the same that we have here,
except the phi is in white.
That's why it's not there.
OK.
All right?
So it's actually simpler than
what's on the slides, I guess.
All right.
So now, if you pay
attention, I actually
never force this g prime
of mu i to be here.
Actually, I even tried to
make a mistake to not have it.
And so this g prime of mu i
shows up completely naturally.
If I had started with this,
you would have never questioned
why I actually didn't
multiply by g prime
and divided by g prime
completely artificially here.
It just shows up
naturally in the weights.
But it's just more
natural for me
to compute the first
derivative first
than the second
derivative second, OK?
And so we just did it
the other way around.
But now, let's assume we
forgot about everything.
We have this.
This is a natural way of
writing it, x transpose wx.
If I want something that
involves some weights,
I have to force them in by
dividing by g prime of mu i
and therefore, multiplying
yi n mu i by this wi.
OK?
So now, if we recap what we've
actually found, we got that--
let me write it here.
We also have that
the expectation
of H ln of beta x transpose xw.
So if I go back to my
iterations over there,
I should actually
update beta k plus 1
to be equal to beta
k plus the inverse.
So that's actually equal
to negative i of beta k--
well, yeah.
That's negative i
of beta, I guess.
Oh, and beta here shows up in
w, right? w depends on beta.
So that's going to be beta k.
So let me call it wk.
So that's the diagonal of
H prime xi transpose beta
k, this time, divided by
g prime of mu i k phi.
OK?
So this beta k induces
a mu by looking
at g inverse of xi
transpose beta k.
All right.
So mu i k is g inverse
of xi transpose beta k.
So that's 2 to the--
sorry, that's an iteration.
And so now, if I actually
write these things together,
I get minus x
transpose wx inverse.
So that's wk.
And then I have my
gradient here that I
have to apply at k,
which is x transpose wk.
And then I have y tilde k minus
mu tilde k, where, again, the
indices--
I mean the superscript
k are pretty natural.
y tilde k just means that--
so that's just yi.
So that's just yi times
g prime of mu i k.
And mu tilde k is, if I
look at the i coordinate,
it's just going to be mu
i times g prime of mu i.
OK?
So I just add superscripts
k to everything.
So I know that those things
get updated real time, right?
Every time I make one iteration,
I get a new value for beta,
I get a new value for
mu, and therefore, I
get a new value for w.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
Fisher equation [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
that's a good point.
So that's definitely
a plus, because this
is a positive,
semi-definite matrix.
So this is a plus.
And well, that's probably
where I erased it.
OK.
Let's see where I
made my mistake.
So there should be a minus here.
There should be a minus here.
There should be a minus even
at the beginning, I believe.
So that means that what
is my-- oh, yeah, yeah.
So you see, when we
go back to the first,
so what I erased was basically
this thing here, yi minus mu i.
And when I took the
first derivative--
so it was the derivative
with respect to H prime.
So the derivative with
respect to the second term--
I mean, the derivative
of the second term
was actually killed,
because we took
the expectation of this guy.
But when we took the derivative
of the first term, which
is the only one that
stayed, this guy went away.
But there was a negative
sign from this guy,
because that's the thing
we took the negative off.
So it's really, when I
take my second derivative,
I should carry out the
minus signs everywhere.
OK?
So it's just I forget
this minus throughout.
You see the first term went
away, on the first line there.
The first term
went away, because
the conditional expectation
of yi, given xi 0.
And then I had this minus
sign in front of everyone,
and I forgot it.
All right.
Any other mistake that I made?
We're good?
All right.
So now, this is what
we have, that xk--
sorry, that beta k plus
1 is equal to beta k
plus this thing.
OK?
And if you look at this
thing, it sort of reminds
us of something.
Remember the least
squares estimator.
So here, I'm going to
actually deviate slightly
from the slides.
And I will tell you how.
The slides take
beta k and put it
in here, which is one way to go.
And just think of this as a
big least square solution.
Or you can keep the beta k,
solve another least squares,
and then add it to the
beta k that you have.
It's the same thing.
So I will take the
different routes.
So you have the two
options, all right?
OK.
So when we did the
least squares--
so parenthesis least squares--
we had y equals x
beta plus epsilon.
And our estimator beta
hat was x transpose
x inverse x transpose y, right?
And that was just solving
the first order condition,
and that's what we found.
Now look at this--
x transpose bleep x inverse,
x transpose bleep something.
OK?
So this looks like, if this
is the same as the left board,
if wk is equal to the
identity matrix, meaning we
don't see it, and y is equal
to y tilde k minus mu tilde k--
so those similarities, the
fact that we just squeeze in--
so the fact that the response
variable is different
is really not a problem.
We just have to
pretend that this
is equal to y tilde
minus mu tilde.
I mean, that's just
the least squares.
When you call a software that
does least squares for you,
you just tell it what y
is, you tell it with x is,
and it makes the computation.
So you would just lie to
it and say all the actual y
I want is this thing.
And then we need to somehow
incorporate those weights.
And so the question
is, is that easy to do?
And the answer is yes,
because this is a setup where
this would actually arise.
So one of the things that's
very specific to what
we did here and with
least squares, we assume
that epsilon, when we did
at least the inference,
we assumed that
epsilon was normal 0
and the covariance matrix
was the identity, right?
What if the covariance
matrix is not the identity?
If the covariance matrix
is not the identity,
then your maximum
likelihood is not exactly
these least squares.
If the covariance
matrix is any matrix
you have another solution,
which involves the inverse
of the covariance
matrix that you have,
but if your covariance matrix,
in particular, is diagonal--
which would mean that
each observation that you
get in this system of
equations is still independent,
but the variances can
change from one line
to another, from one
observation to another--
then it's called
heteroscedastic.
"Hetero" means "not the same."
"Scedastic" is "scale."
And a heteroscedastic
case, you would have
something slightly different.
And it makes sense
that, if you know
that some observations have
much less variance than others,
you might want to
give them more weight.
OK?
So if you think about
your usual drawing,
and maybe you have
something like this,
but the actual line is really--
OK, let's say you have this guy
as well, so just a few here.
If you start drawing this
thing, if you do least squares,
you're going to see
something that looks
like this on those points.
But now, if I tell you
that, on this side,
the variance is equal to 100,
meaning that those points are
actually really far
from the true one,
and here on this side, the
variance is equal to 1,
meaning that those points are
actually close to the line
you're looking for, then the
line you should be fitting
is probably this
guy, meaning do not
trust the guys that
have a lot of variance.
And so you need somehow
to incorporate that.
If you know that those things
have much more variance
than these guys, you
want to weight this.
And the way you do it is by
using weighted least squares.
OK.
So we're going to
open in parentheses
on weighted least squares.
It's not a fundamental
statistical question,
but it's useful for us,
because this is exactly
what's going to spit out--
something that looks like this
with this matrix w in there.
OK.
So let's go back in
time for a second.
Assume we're still covering
least squares regression.
So now, I'm going to assume
that y is x beta plus epsilon,
but this time, epsilon is a
multivariate Gaussian in, say,
p dimensions with mean 0.
And covariance matrix, I
will write it as w inverse,
because w is going to be the
one that's going to show up.
OK?
So this is the so-called
heteroscedastic.
That's how it's spelled,
and yet another name
that you can pick for your
soccer team or a capella group.
All right.
So the maximum
likelihood, in this case--
so actually, let's compute
the maximum likelihood
for this problem, right?
So the log likelihood is what?
Well, we're going to have
the term that tells us
that it's going to be-- so OK.
What is the density of
a multivariate Gaussian?
So it's going to be a
multivariate Gaussian
in p dimension with mean x
beta and covariance matrix w
inverse, right?
So that's the
density that we want.
Well, it's of the form 1 over
determinant of w inverse times
2 pi to the p/2.
OK?
And times exponential, and now,
what I have is x minus x beta
transpose w-- so that's
the inverse of w inverse--
x minus x beta divided by 2.
OK?
So this is x minus mu
transpose sigma inverse x
minus mu divided by 2.
And if you want a sanity
check, just assume that sigma--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it x
minus x beta or y?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Well, you
know, if you want this to be y,
then this is y, right?
Sure.
Yeah, maybe it's less confusing.
So if you should do p is equal
to 1, then what does it mean?
It means that you
have this mean here.
So let's forget
about what it is.
But this guy is going to be
just 1 sigma squared, right?
So what you see here is the
inverse of sigma squared.
So that's going to be 2 over 2
sigma squared, like we usually
see it.
The determinant of
w inverse is just
the product of
the entry of the 1
by 1 matrix, which
is just sigma square.
OK?
So that should be actually--
yeah, no, that's actually--
yeah, that's sigma square.
And then I have this 2 pi.
So square root of this,
because p is equal to 1,
I get sigma square
root 2 pi, which is
the normalization that I get.
This is not going
to matter, because,
when I look at
the log likelihood
as a function of beta--
so I'm assuming
that w is known--
what I get is something
which is a constant.
So it's minus p minus
n times p/2 times
log that w inverse times 2 pi.
OK?
So this is just going
to be a constant.
It won't matter when I do
the maximum likelihood.
And then I'm going to have what?
I'm going to have plus 1/2
of y minus x beta transpose w
y minus x beta.
So if I want to take the
maximum of this guy--
sorry, there's a minus here.
So if I want to take
the maximum of this guy,
I'm going to have to take
the minimum of this thing.
And the minimum of this thing,
if you take the derivative,
you get to see--
so that's what we have, right?
We need to compute
the minimum of y
minus x beta transpose
w minus y minus x beta.
And the solution that you get--
I mean, you can actually
check this for yourself.
The way you can see this
is by doing the following.
If you're lazy and you don't
want to redo the entire thing--
maybe I should keep that guy.
W is diagonal, right?
I'm going to assume that
so w inverse is diagonal,
and I'm going to assume that
no variance is equal to 0
and no variance is
equal to infinity,
so that both w inverse and
w have only positive entries
on the diagonal.
All right?
So in particular, I can
talk about the square root
of w, which is just the
matrix, the diagonal matrix,
with the square roots
on the diagonal.
OK?
And so I want to minimize in
beta y minus x beta transpose w
y minus x beta.
So I'm going to write
w as square root
of w times square root of
w, which I can, because w--
and it's just the
simplest thing, right?
If w is w1 wn, so that's my
w, then the square root of w
is just square root of
w1 square root of wn,
and then 0 is elsewhere.
OK?
So the product of
those two matrices
gives me definitely
back what I want,
and that's the usual
matrix product.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to push one on one side
and push the other
one on the other side.
So that gives me
that this is really
the minimum over beta of--
well, here I have
this transposed,
so I have to put it
on the other side.
w is clearly symmetric and
so is square root of w.
So the transpose doesn't matter.
And so what I'm left
with is square root
of wy minus square root of wx
beta transpose, and then times
itself.
So that's square root
wy minus square root w--
oh, I don't have enough space--
x beta.
OK, and that stops here.
But this is the same thing
that we've been doing before.
This is a new y.
Let's call it y prime.
This is a new x.
Let's call it x prime.
And now, this is just the
least squares estimator
associated to a response y prime
and a design matrix x prime.
So I know that the solution is x
prime transpose x prime inverse
x prime transpose y prime.
And now, I'm just going
to substitute again
what my x prime is in
terms of x and what
my y prime is in terms of y.
And that gives me exactly x
square root w square root w
x inverse.
And then I have x transpose
square root w for this guy.
And then I have square
root wy for that guy.
And that's exactly
what I wanted.
I'm left with x transpose
wx inverse x transpose wy.
OK?
So that's a simple way
to take into account
the w that we had before.
And you could actually do it
with any matrix that's positive
semi-definite, because
you can actually
talk about the square
root of those matrices.
And it's just the square root
of a matrix is just a matrix
such that, when you
multiply it by itself,
it gives you the
original matrix.
OK?
So here, that was
just a shortcut
that consisted in
saying, OK, maybe I
don't want to recompute the
gradient of this quantity,
set it equal to 0, and see
what beta hat had should be.
Instead, I am going to
assume that I already
know that, if I
did not have the w,
I would know how to solve it.
And that's exactly what I did.
I said, well, I
know that this is
the minimum of something
that looks like this,
when I have the primes.
And then I just substitute
back my w in there.
All right.
So that' just the
lazy computation.
But again, if you
don't like it, you
can always take the
gradient of this guy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is
the solution written
in the slides different?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Because there's a mistake.
Yeah, there's a
mistake on the slides.
How did I make that one?
I'm actually trying
to parse it back.
I mean, it's clearly
wrong, right?
Oh, no, it's not.
No, it is.
So it's not clearly wrong.
Actually, it is clearly wrong.
Because if I put
the identity here,
those are still
associative, right?
So this product is
actually not compatible.
So it's wrong, but there's
just this extra thing
that I probably copy-pasted
from some place.
Since this is one
of my latest slide,
I'll just color it in white.
But yeah, sorry, there's a mis--
this parenthesis is not here.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
OK?
AUDIENCE: So why not
square root [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Because
I have two of them.
I have one that comes from the
x prime that's here, this guy.
And then I have one that
comes from this guy here.
OK, so the solution--
let's write it in some place
that's actually legible--
which is the correction
for this thing
is x transpose wx
inverse x transpose wy.
OK?
So you just squeeze
in this w in there.
And that's exactly
what we had before,
x transpose wx inverse
x transpose w some y.
OK?
And what I claim is that this
is routinely implemented.
As you can imagine,
heteroscedastic linear
regression is something
that's very common.
So every time you a
least squares formula,
you also have a way to
put in some weights.
You don't have to
put diagonal weights,
but here, that's all we need.
So here on the slides,
again, I took the beta k,
and I put it in there, so that
I have only one least square
solution to formulate.
But let's do it
slightly differently.
What I'm going to
do here now is I'm
going to say, OK, let's feed
it to some least squares.
So let's do weighted least
squares on a response,
y being y tilde k minus mu tilde
k, and design matrix being,
well, just the x itself.
So that doesn't change.
And the weights-- so
the weights are what?
The weights are the
wk that I had here.
So wki is h prime
of xi transpose beta
k divided by g prime of
mu i at time k times phi.
OK, and so this, if I solve
it, will spit out something
that I will call a solution.
I will call it u hat k plus 1.
And to get beta
hat k plus 1, all I
need to do is to do beta
k plus u hat k plus 1--
sorry, beta-- yeah.
OK?
And that's because-- so
here, that's not clear.
But I started from
there, remember?
I started from this guy here.
So I'm just solving a least
squares, a weighted least
square that's going
to give me this thing.
That's what I called
u hat k plus 1.
And then I add it to beta k, and
that gives me beta k minus 1.
So I just have this
intermediate step,
which is removed in the slides.
OK?
So then you can repeat
until convergence.
What does it mean to
repeat until convergence?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, exactly.
So you just set some
threshold and you say,
I promise you that this
will converge, right?
So you know that at some point,
you're going to be there.
You're going to go
there, but you're never
going to be exactly there.
And so you just say, OK, I
want this accuracy on my data.
Actually, the machine
is a little strong.
Especially if you have 10
observations to start with,
you know you're going to
have something that's going
to have some statistical error.
So that should actually guide
you into what kind of error
you want to be making.
So for example, a
good rule of thumb
is that if you have
n observations,
you just take some within--
if you want the L2
distance between the beta--
the two consecutive beta
to be less than 1/n,
you should be good enough.
It doesn't have to be
that machine precision.
And so it's clear how
we do this, right?
So here, I just have to maintain
a bunch of things, right?
So remember, when I want to
recompute-- at every step,
I have to recompute
a bunch of things.
So I have to
recompute the weights.
But if I want to recompute
the weights, not only do
I need to previous
iterate, but I
need to know how the previous
iterate impacts my means.
So at each step, I have
to recalculate mu i k
by doing g prime, rate?
Remember mu i k was just g
inverse of xi transpose beta k,
right?
So I have to recompute that.
And then I use this
to compute my weights.
I also use this to
compute my y, right?
so my y depends also
on g prime of mu i k.
I feed that to my weighted
least squares engine.
It spits out the u hat k, that
I add to my previous beta k.
And that gives me my
new beta k plus 1.
OK.
So here's the
pseudocode, if you want
to take some time to parse it.
All right.
So here again, the
trick is not much.
It's just saying, if you don't
feel like implementing Fisher
scoring or inverting your
Hessian at every step,
then a weighted least
squares is actually going
to do it for you automatically.
All right.
Then that's just
a numerical trick.
There's nothing really
statistical about this,
except the fact that this
calls for a solution for each
of the step reminded us
of sum of the squares,
except that there was
some extra weights.
OK.
So to conclude, we'll
need to know, of course,
xy, the link function.
Why do we need the
variance function?
I'm not sure we actually
need the variance function.
No, I don't know why I say that.
You need phi, not the
variance function.
So where do you start
actually, right?
So clearly, if you start
very close to your solution,
you're actually going
to do much better.
And one good way to start--
so for the beta itself, it's
not clear what it's going to be.
But you can actually
get a good idea
of what beta is by just having
a good idea of what mu is.
Because mu is g inverse
of xi transpose beta.
And so what you
could do is to try
to set mu to be the actual
observations that you have,
because that's the
best guess that you
have for their expected value.
And then you just say,
OK, once I have my mu,
I know that my mu is a
function of this thing.
So I can write g of mu and solve
it, using your least squares
estimator, right?
So g of mu is of
the form x beta.
So you just solve for--
once you have your mu,
you pass it through g, and
then you solve for the beta
that you want.
And then that's the beta
that you initialize with.
OK?
And actually, this was your
question from last time.
As soon as I use
the canonical link,
Fisher scoring
and Newton-Raphson
are the same thing, because
the Hessian is actually
deterministic in that
case, just because when
you use the canonical link,
H is the identity, which
means that its second
derivative is equal to 0.
So this term goes away even
without taking the expectation.
So remember, the
term that went away
was of the form yi
minus mu i divided
by phi times h prime prime
of xi transpose beta, right?
That's the term that we said,
oh, the conditional expectation
of this guy is 0.
But if h prime prime
is already equal to 0,
then there's nothing
that changes.
There's nothing that goes away.
It was already equal to 0.
And that always happens when
you have the canonical link,
because h is g b prime inverse.
And the canonical link
is b prime inverse,
so this thing is the identity.
So the second derivative of
f of x is equal to x is 0.
OK.
My screen says end of show.
So we can start
with some questions.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to clarify.
So iterative-- what is
it say for iterative--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Reweighted least squares.
AUDIENCE: Reweighted
least squares
is an implementation of the
Fisher scoring [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
That's an implementation
that's just making calls to
weighted least squares oracles.
It's called an oracle sometimes.
An oracle is what you assume the
machine can do easily for you.
So if you assume
that your machine is
very good at multiplying
by the inverse of a matrix,
you might as well just do
Fisher scoring yourself, right?
It's just a way so that you
don't have to actually do it.
And usually, those
things are implemented--
and I just said routinely--
in statistical software.
But they're implemented
very efficiently
in statistical software.
So this is going to be one
of the fastest ways you're
going to have to
solve, to do this step,
especially for
large-scale problems.
AUDIENCE: So the thing
that computers can do well
is the multiplier [INAUDIBLE].
What's the thing that
the computers can do fast
and what's the thing
that [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So if you were
to do this in the
simplest possible way,
your iterations for,
say, Fisher scoring
is just multiply by the inverse
of the Fisher information,
right?
AUDIENCE: So finding
that inverse is slow?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
so it takes a bit of time.
Whereas, since you know you're
going to multiply directly
by something, if you just say--
those things are not
as optimized as solving
least squares.
Actually, the way
it's typically done
is by doing some least squares.
So you might as well just do
least squares that you like.
And there's also less--
well, no, there's no--
well, there is less
recalculation, right?
Here, your Fisher,
you would have
to recompute the entire
matrix of Fisher information.
Whereas here, you don't have to.
Right?
You really just have to compute
some vectors and the vector
of weights, right?
So the Fisher information
matrix has, say,
n choose two entries that
you need to compute, right?
It's symmetric, so it's
order n squared entries.
But here, the only things you
update, if you think about it,
are this weight matrix.
So there is only the
diagonal elements
that you need to update, and
these vectors in there also.
There's two inverses n squared.
So that's much less thing
to actually put in there.
It does it for you somehow.
Any other question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if I have
a data set [INAUDIBLE],,
then I can always try to model
it with least squares, right?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, you can.
AUDIENCE: And so this is like
setting my weight equal to 1--
the identity,
essentially, right?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Well, not exactly,
because the g also shows
up in this correction
that you have here, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I mean, I
don't know what you mean by--
AUDIENCE: I'm just
trying to say,
are there ever situations where
I'm trying to model a data set
and I would want to pick my
weights in a particular way?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I mean--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
example [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Well, OK, there's
the heteroscedastic
case for sure.
So if you're going to actually
compute those things-- and more
generally, I don't
think you should think
of those as being weights.
You should really think
of those as being matrices
that you invert.
And don't think of
it as being diagonal,
but really think of them
as being full matrices.
So if you have--
when we wrote weighted least
squares here, this was really--
the w, I said, is diagonal.
But all the computations really
never really use the fact
that it's diagonal.
So what shows up here
is just the inverse
of your covariance matrix.
And so if you have
data that's correlated,
this is where it's
going to show up.